(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
- [Kelly] It's been a minute!
You were here a bit ago.
- Yeah, and actually, it
was during COVID, remember?
- That,
- [Kelly] I know.
- It was like a sci-fi,
- The screen.
- Yeah, the screens.
- Yes.
That was when I talked to
everybody via a screen.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yes.
I like you physically in person more.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- Yes.
- We can like, touch.
- Thank you, yeah, yeah.
- So good to see the audience.
- So wait, it's New Year's now.
So what do y'all do in Venezuela?
Do you have any, like,
special things y'all do?
- In Venezuela many,
there is one that I used to do
when I was a kid.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it really paid off.
- [Kelly] What?
- You go around, I mean,
when the clock hits 00:00
you hug everybody and
then you take a suitcase
and go around the block,
running around the block,
and that will give you a lot of travels.
You know,
during the year.
- [Kelly] I like this.
- So I did it a lot when I was a kid
and now I'm traveling all the time.
- You're traveling all the time, it works!
Do it, kids!
- That's what it pays off.
- Do it.
There's something with
grapes, as well, right?
- Oh, yeah.
- Because I think
they do the same thing in Mexico.
'Cause I was in Mexico
once and they were like,
all of a sudden, there
were grapes at the table,
and I think they do the same thing
in Venezuela.
- The same thing.
- [Kelly] I had no idea.
- So it is 12 grapes
for the months of the year.
It's 12 months, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
- There are 12 months.
- Yeah, exactly.
So it's 12 wishes.
- Yeah.
- And then right before
the clock hits 00:00,
then you have to eat them.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And make a wish
for each grape.
- Yeah.
- I thought whenever I was doing it,
I heard someone,
'cause I was drinking tequila.
- Yeah, of course.
- And I heard them say,
"You have to eat it in the first minute."
- Yeah.
- But I think it's actually
have to eat them each minute.
Like the first 12 minutes.
So I was like, just, just,
I wanted my wishes to come true.
- [Edgar] I was just like you.
- I ate them so fast.
- Yeah, I would always do it
in the 12 seconds before.
- Yeah, I did it.
Yeah, somebody was like, no, no, no.
It was, like, one a minute.
And I was, like, "No, I didn't hear that."
Anyway, I got my wishes, though.
So there you go.
- [Edgar] Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Well, speaking of travel,
Edgar actually recently went to Croatia,
so here's a video.
- [Kelly] What's happening man?
- [Edgar] Oh my God.
- [Kelly] What is this dance?
- [Edgar] If I only knew
what was happening there.
- [Kelly] I feel like I did
this in show choir once.
- [Edgar] I ended up on a
boat with a bunch of Croatian
and Bosnian people
and then suddenly, they played that music.
They started to dance
and I just joined in.
- [Kelly] I like it.
- So yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's like a folk.
- [Kelly] It feels good.
- Yeah, it feels good, yeah.
- I like jumping.
It's good for lymphatic system.
- [Edgar] Yeah.
- It's perfect.
(Kelly laughs)
- Do you like dancing in general?
- Yeah, I'm from Venezuela so, yeah.
- He said, "Yes, yes."
I love dancing.
- [Edgar] Yeah, I love dancing too.
- Makes me feel so good.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay, we have
something else in common.
You love collecting watches.
- [Edgar] Yeah, I do.
- Yeah, so I love giving watches.
- [Edgar] Okay.
- As a gift, 'cause I
don't wear them generally,
but I love -
- It's Christmas.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
I'm just saying I love watches.
I don't actually like knowing the time,
which is weird because it rushes me
and I wanna live my life.
But I love watches.
Like the art of them are so beautiful.
- Yeah, I mean, what you love,
what you love is,
is the beauty of the watches.
- Yeah.
- It's almost like jewelry.
- And you're right, I always
get 'em like engraved,
like with a little message when I give,
yeah.
- [Edgar] Ah, that's very cute.
- So you collect them, right?
- [Edgar] I collect, yeah.
I mean, I used to say
that I had a watch collection,
but actually now it's my
dad's watch collection,
'cause every time he
comes visit and he says,
"Oh, that watch so cute, can I have it?"
(audience laughs)
- Takes your watch.
- [Edgar] Oh, it's so cute,
can I use it for a little bit?
And then he just takes it home, so now,
- [Kelly] You and your
father have a collection.
- [Edgar] So now it's like,
our watch collection, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Edgar] It used to be mine,
but now, well.
- [Kelly] I love.
- It's gonna be mine anyway.
- [Kelly] Do you get into pocket watches?
That's what I'm obsessed
with, specifically.
- [Edgar] Pocket watches, I don't know.
- I just think they're
so cool with the chain.
- But the ones that you,
with the chain, oh no,
I have, well, I should,
I should look into that.
- Oh, man.
- Yeah.
- They're really cool.
- But they're, but you do, but you do,
- [Kelly] Look, I tried,
- But you have the chain, right?
- Well, I give them as
gifts like a lot of times.
Like I've, or I've done it a few,
yeah, they're very cool.
- Yeah.
- Do you have significance
behind this watch?
- [Edgar] Yeah, I mean, it was a gift.
- Oh.
- It was a gift for, for a very, you know,
special premiere at the, you know,
Cannes Film Festival in France.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then I had this big movie
and I walk up this, you
know, the red carpet,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
The stairs, yeah.
- It was pretty, yeah,
it was pretty, you know,
it's a, it's a beautiful
life, you know that we have
- Yes, very blessed.
- [Edgar] It's like a reminder of
that maybe some things
have been done well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, so it's like, I don't know.
- [Kelly] You did some things right?
Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah exactly, so.
- Yeah, I love that.
I don't like anything unless
there's meaning behind it.
I like a meaning.
- [Edgar] Yeah, totally.
- Because I'm not really
materialistic in general.
- No, no, no.
It's how, how the intention
is bound to the to the object.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's not the object on, on itself.
- [Kelly] Yeah, agreed.
- It's the memories and what, you know,
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- The beautiful memories
that they bring to you.
- [Kelly] I agree.
That's why I like tattoos as well.
- [Edgar] Yeah.
- I'm covered.
- I don't have, I, yeah,
I don't have tattoos.
- [Kelly] Oh, man.
- At all.
I haven't found like an image to.
- [Kelly] Don't, if you
find one, don't worry,
then you'll find 20 more.
- [Edgar] That's what happens, yeah.
- Yeah, You get one
and then you're like, this is fun,
and then.
- [Edgar] Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, mine are all memories,
the same kind of thing.
Mine are all, you know,
places and things and that.
- And you can look at all of them, or?
- No, not the one,
I often forget there's one
on my back right shoulder,
I forgot.
And I got that in Amsterdam.
I was not high.
- Okay.
(everyone laughs)
- I got it because there's Hanky there.
He did a lot of us on tour
when we were there touring.
And I was like, and it hurt.
(Kelly chuckles)
But I did it, and it's big, but anyway.
So I heard that you were
a journalist at one point.
- Yeah, I was a journalist before.
- So what, when did that
career switch happen?
- Well, you know what,
and that brings me back to the,
to the New Year's tradition.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I always wanted, I
always wanted to travel.
That was, I wanted to be a journalist
so that I could get,
become a international
correspondent so that I could travel.
- Yeah.
- And I always, and I also
wanted to be a diplomat,
'cause my dad was a military attache
and sort of like a military diplomat.
- Yeah.
- So I wanted to do something in life
that would allow me to travel
and get to know interesting people
and have great conversations.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that's pretty much what I'm doing.
- [Kelly] I was like, both
those jobs entail that.
- [Edgar] Exactly, so then,
there was something that happens
towards my last year at University.
A friend of mine invited
me to do a short film.
And then I said, but I'm not an actor.
And I said, well, but I
need like, someone like you.
It's like an experimental
abstract, weird short film.
- Wait, they called.
Oh, I thought that he was saying,
I need someone like you, weird, abstract.
I thought he was describing the character.
- Yeah, exactly like with
a comma or a big comma,
weird like that.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Someone like you, comma weird, abstract.
And all I had to do was just to make out
with this girl in a latex suit.
- [Kelly] Wow.
In a latex suit?
- Yeah, they bleached my hair.
I know that's gonna, that's gonna bite me.
- [Kelly] I wanna,
I wanna find this.
- [Edgar] That's gonna come back to me.
- Yeah.
- [Edgar] Soon, I don't know.
Well, but yes, that exists somewhere.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And then it turned out to be a quite,
you know, apparently decent short film.
And then it got selected in a
film festival for students.
- You got the bug.
- And then one thing led to another.
And then here I am
talking to Kelly Clarkson.
- Yeah and you're so good.
(audience applauds)
- You're such a great actor.
It's so interesting that you haven't
had that dream, like, since you're a kid,
'cause you're so good at it.
- [Edgar] Thank you so much.
- Yeah.
That was a look at his series,
Dr. Death, you can see it on Peacock.
(audience cheering)
Man.
This story is crazy.
And it's crazy because it's real.
So why, why did you wanna do this series?
- Because it's crazy, and it's real.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it went on for too long.
- [Kelly] Right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a, it's, it's a very.
I love the show and I love
the idea of working with
Mandy Moore, who's amazing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And to fall in love with her in this
very twisted love story, but
a love story nonetheless.
So it is true crime,
but I think it shows very interesting,
'cause it has a love story
right at the core of it.
And I think that that
also increases tension
because you know that
it's a doomed love story.
- Yeah.
- So I don't wanna give out too much.
- Yeah and the fact that she's
an investigative reporter.
- [Edgar] Yeah, and then, and
then this guy basically was,
is a con artist, you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he.
- [Kelly] Brilliantly done.
- Brilliantly and he
was lying to everybody.
But for him it was a fantasy.
He was fantasizing.
He was in the middle of a fantasy
and committed to his, to his fantasy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Just a complete narcissist.
- [Edgar] Yeah, absolutely,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Edgar] So, so it was very,
it was a good challenge.
It was a very interesting
challenge for me.
- Yeah, I think it would be kind
of fun if you're an
actor to play a role like
that rather than like a normal, like it's,
I don't know, it seems more fun to play
someone that's more like out there.
- Normally, when people are the,
you know, at the unfortunate receiving end
of a manipulation or a deceit,
the question's always,
how could she believe him?
How could they believe those lies?
- Yeah.
- But that shouldn't be the question.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- The question is, how can someone
devote their entire talents
to damage other people,
- [Kelly] And how does
that not make you sick?
Yeah.
- Yeah exactly.
But this guy there, he will never,
there was never an admission of.
- [Kelly] No remorse.
- No remorse, no accountability,
so yeah, it was.
- [Kelly] Major God Complex.
- [Edgar] It was very tense.
Yeah.
- So, I don't know, you've such a
great relationship with your doctors,
'cause I've heard that you and maybe some
of your family members
have a heart condition.
- [Edgar] Yeah, exactly.
- So you've had like a great relationship
with doctors your whole life.
- [Edgar] Yeah that's
the thing, that's right.
Yeah, that's why the whole thing was so,
was such a sensitive matter
for me because I know how,
- But can you imagine if you
had a doctor like that though?
- [Edgar] No of course not.
That's the thing that,
I know how important it
is to trust your doctors.
You know, I've had very close
relationships with doctors
due to my family's, you
know, health conditions
and the one that I had when I was a kid.
So I know how important
it is to trust them
and how much hope you put in them.
So for this character, for this person to,
to betray that trust.
I mean, he knew, he knew
his patient's names,
he knew their dreams, he
knew their relative's names
and he was able to,
- Take that in and still betray.
That is so crazy to me.
Well, you mentioned Mandy Moore.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Playing your
love interest, I love her.
Easy to fall in love with.
- [Edgar] I mean, so easy
to fall in love with her.
(audience applause)
- But how did you guys,
how did you guys keep.
Oh my God, y'all look- like right there.
You look like,
when you buy a picture frame at a store,
you look like the couple.
That's amazing.
- That's where we are, we are the couple.
- That's amazing.
- That's so cute.
- So how did you guys
keep it light though?
'Cause it's a very intense film.
- We hit it off right away.
We met shortly before we start shooting.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In L.A. we shot most of
the show here in New York.
And the chemistry was just
right there, you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We really, we were able to
trust each other right away
and become each other's safety net
because, you know, these
waters were very murky.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Navigate the waters of this show.
But we are very similar.
We have very similar work ethics.
And we're both Aries.
That's my.
- Oh, you're both leaders.
- [Edgar] Yeah.
- Okay.
- [Edgar] Yeah, but we,
we hit it off right away.
And we really have very similar
ways to approach the work.
- That's helpful.
- So we committed to
the story very strongly,
and then by the time we wrapped,
we were already back to normal.
So, we.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We put everything,
- That's so cool actors
can do that, just go in
and like be this other human
and then like, go to dinner that night.
- [Edgar] Yeah, that's
exactly what we did.
- [Kelly] That is crazy.
- Yeah.
- You're really good liars.
- But you know, but you know what?
That's the thing, that's the thing.
And that relates to my character.
We're not, a lot of people
assume that from actors.
- I was totally being playful, yeah.
- No, I know, but it's, I know.
But it's interesting because,
- You have to believe you're actually.
- Acting is a, is an explore,
you within the context of acting,
everything within it is fictional.
But your relationship to it is real.
- [Kelly] Is real, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So you're doing the opposite of lying.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You are fantasizing.
- Which is different from lying.
You're believing what is happening to you.
- I love fantasizing.
- [Edgar] Yeah, exactly.
(audience laughs)
It is a huge difference.
So, and that also is
what my character did.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, so
- [Kelly] That's what he
did in life, he had to.
- Exactly, yeah.
So it was like.
- [Kelly] Some type of
compartmentalization.
- Absolutely.
- [Kelly] Man.
Do you ever, we were talking in the break,
how you love to snowboard.
- [Edgar] Yeah.
- You learned skills like this for movies
and roles that you do.
- Yeah, I did.
- Do you keep a lot of
those, like afterwards?
- Well, yeah.
I mean, I keep, I, yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh, beautiful.
- [Edgar] That's, it was in Montana.
- [Kelly] Oh really?
- That's in Montana, yeah actually, yeah.
- Where are you at in Montana?
- In Big Sky.
- Big Sky, okay, cool.
- Yeah, it was Big Sky.
- Yeah.
- So I love snowboarding.
I picked it up when I did point break.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I did the reboot of Point Break,
I played Bodhi's character.
The one that,
the one that Patrick Swayze
played in the first one.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So I picked that up,
and then from my boxing movie,
'Hands of Stone',
I got the watch from,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That is the premiere,
I picked up boxing.
So, from those characters,
- That's a good healthy thing.
- From this one, I mean from Dr. Death,
I try not to.
- Yeah, don't take,
- [Edgar] I don't take any, yeah.
- Don't take any of those,
those moments with you.
- Maybe some piece of clothes,
'cause I mean, he, he dress well.
- Oh my God.
- So yeah.
- Just, yeah nice.
- Yeah.
- Don't you love that
sometimes you're like,
so can I take this home?
- Of course yeah.
Yeah, like my dad.
- [Kelly] Like your dad.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, I like that.
- [Kelly] Well, Apple tree,
you're not far from it.
- [Edgar] Exactly, exactly.
I really like this boots.
Can I have them?
Yeah.
- [Kelly] Because they're nice sometimes.
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] Like, can I
find those anywhere else?
Okay, so wait, a movie
that we watch so much
at my household is 'Jungle Cruise'.
- [Edgar] Yeah.
- And we love you in that.
- [Edgar] Thank you.
- But your role is crazy.
You had all the gross things on you
and coming out of your mouth.
- [Edgar] Yeah.
- [Kelly] And all the orifices.
And I heard your mother was not a fan.
- Yeah, she's not a fan.
And when she came to the premier with me
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- At Disneyland.
And then,
it went exactly how I imagined it.
It's like the minute,
like the snakes start come out of my face.
Then she say like, you didn't tell me,
you did it on purpose.
You did on purpose.
And she covered her eyes.
And I said, yeah, did it on purpose.
I wanna,
- [Kelly] It's a gnarly,
they did a really good job.
- Yeah, that was neat.
- I looked at my kids the very first time
we watching it and both of
them were just like horrified.
They were like, like just frozen.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- [Kelly] But it's such a great film.
- And a snake coming 'outta my.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Is it weird to act like that?
Like, 'cause it,
obviously we are seeing it once it's done,
but you're having to act
- No, it's super easy,
'cause they put just like some dots
on your face and then everything
is just computer magic.
- [Kelly] That does not
sound super easy, but okay.
- Yeah.
(Edgar laughs)
- That's why you're an actor and I'm not.
Okay, well let's do a
commercial break, everybody.
You can see the very creepy,
very disturbed Dr. Death on Peacock.
- Alright, we're back
here with Edgar Ramirez!
(audience cheering)
You can see him now in the
Peacock Series, Dr. Death.
It's about a super creepy doctor who gets
way, way too obsessed with his work.
Which means it's time for us
to talk about our much less creepy,
hopefully much less creepy, obsessions.
(soft music)
- [Jessie] Obsessions.
- [Kelly] Oh, well I need to say it
like Jessie, next time.
This is my problem.
It was very sexy.
I'll hit this button right here.
And a topic will be selected
by our super janky super computer.
The button does nothing.
Then the person obsessed with the topic,
will own up and sell everybody on it.
So let's go, I'm first, 'cause I say so.
- Okay.
(seductive music)
(bell dinging)
Okay, what's up first?
Oh, YouTube, okay.
So my son, he's seven
and he loves drawing.
- Okay.
- And he figured out on
YouTube there's like tutorials
that you can literally, they
walk you through drawing.
I can't draw at all.
Like, not good at all.
And anyway, we follow them.
We do them almost every night.
And we would do like the headless horse.
He was like, can you draw
the headless horse mom?
I was like, no, I cannot do that.
And then he found this thing and,
and I ended up doing it.
They really, you should try it.
You feel incredible when you're done.
But anyway, they take you step by step.
And we do it all the time.
I have a latest one,
I brought it so you could see this is,
look at that.
Look at that.
(audience reacts)
- [Edgar] Oh, that's very cute.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Look, and here's the best part.
The best part is that my son
is not forgiving at all.
And he is like,
yeah, the hat is like
way bigger than it looks,
than it should look.
And I was like, I'm so proud of this.
- [Edgar] Of course.
- And he was like, and he was like,
yeah, it's just he kept
bringing up the hat.
- [Edgar] Yeah.
- And then I didn't wanna
be like, look at yours,
but like, like.
(audience laughing)
So I didn't do that, I didn't do that.
I wanted to do it.
I was like, yeah.
I felt pretty good about it, Edgar.
- Yeah, it's pretty nice
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Chip and Dale.
- I would try, I would try tutorials
because,
- It's fun!
- I suck at drawing, too.
- I'm not good at it either.
But I will tell you,
he totally turned me around on it.
And these people are amazing at
how they teach you like step by step.
It's like a line, then a line,
and then all of a sudden
you're like, am I amazing?
- It's perfect.
- Anyway, it's not that amazing, anyway.
- Okay.
(seductive music)
(bell dinging)
- [Kelly] What is this?
- [Edgar] Sleeping with
thick, fuzzy socks.
- I do this.
- I can't.
- Love it.
- If I'm not next to a body of water,
my feet needs to be covered.
- I'm sorry, wait, what?
- If I'm not, if I'm not in the water,
meaning like on the beach.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or by a pool and my
feet can touch the water,
I need to cover my feet.
Like my feet cannot be.
- You always wear socks.
- Always, I always wear socks.
- Oh, I thought you just
meant in your sleep.
- I cannot, I mean, I sleep naked.
- Do you ever do this thing
where you get hot in the
night though and you have to kick 'em off?
- [Edgar] What the?
- Like in the middle of
the night you get hot.
- No never.
- [Kelly] And then you
kick them off and then
put 'em back on the morning.
- No, I kick off the blanket.
But never the socks, yeah.
- Oh.
- [Edgar] The socks stays on, yeah.
- See I keep the blanket,
kick off the socks
and then I put them back on in
the morning 'cause I'm cold.
- Yeah.
- We're weird.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, I was just thinking that
I do clip my toenails.
- Yeah, good for you.
- You know, so it's not about like
hiding my feet, you know?
I mean, it's not like, I'm like,
- [Kelly] They're not gnarly.
- You know like, my dad
was in the military.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, you know, like,
like clean nails are important, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And polished shoes.
- I'm like trying to hide mine right now.
I'm like, I don't know what
mine look like right now.
But yeah, mine always stay clean too.
I'm hiding 'em.
Yeah, well look, they're just very basic.
They're like, whatever.
Okay, last one, this is Edgar's.
Go ahead.
(seductive music)
- [Jessie] Obsession.
(bell dinging)
- [Kelly] What is this?
Winter hats shaped like animals.
- I mean, you gotta have some fun, right?
- Wait, what?
- So, well it's, I just like
winter hats with like animal
shapes, like with funny.
Funny I guess.
- [Kelly] Like, like a actual,
Oh, yes.
- [Edgar] There you go.
- [Kelly] And you look like
you're having a good time.
- I was, but you know what,
that's pictures do lie.
I was having such a bad time.
I was so sick when I took that picture.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Edgar] So sick.
And I was having tea.
I was having this Argentinian,
Uruguayan Mate tea.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, for the Argentinians,
for the people in the audience.
- Is that really good
for you when you're sick?
- It's really good when you're sick.
It's good for everything.
- [Kelly] I wanna know the secret, okay.
- Yeah, it's really good,
and I was wearing, yeah my,
how do you call that frog?
Like that frog.
- [Kelly] The frog.
- Karmel, Karmel?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Kermit.
- We're gonna call him
Karmel though, yeah.
We're gonna, yeah.
- The accent.
- Yeah, I love it, I love it.
Okay, those are our,
(seductive music)
[Jessie] Obsessions.
(audience cheering)
- Be sure to watch Edgar's show,
Dr. Death it's on Peacock, y'all.